Hans gorg msen Germany's former head of
the office to counter right-wing
extremism is now reportedly under
investigation for right-wing
extremism kind of funny huh according to
the Press Masen has landed on the wrong
side of the office he used to lead
because of his quote increasingly
radical commentary on mass migration
into Germany The Man spent a lot of time
researching what is going on in Germany
and after learning a lot he ended up on
the right now I am not particularly
interested in German politics but I am
interested in the political principle
that can be deduced from this case
namely that the greatest predictor of
right-wing extremism
today is knowledge of politics I'm
Michael nolles this is the Michael
nolles
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show Elmo asked
people how we were doing and the
internet broke down over it we'll get
we'll get to Elmo in just a second first
though speaking of the threat from the
far right and trying to make sense of
these far right-wing extremists the
guardian has has a helpful guideance
out the guardian has a headline to beat
Trump we need to know why Americans keep
voting for him psychologists may have
the
answer they're asking psychologists they
could ask um economists they could ask
sociologists they could ask uh border
patrol agents they could
ask why would anyone ever vote for Trump
um because people don't like when
uh millions and millions of foreigners
illegally flood into their country and
invade their country they don't like
when our jobs are shipped overseas
that's been a long simmering tension for
a long time they don't like when there's
a ton of crime in the streets they
actually don't like dirty syringes and
human feces on their sidewalks they're
not big fans of that what's the
psychological explanation for the
aversion to syringes and excrement uh I
don't know I think it's called being
normal that's the
psychological uh uh basis for it this
headline I've seen a million of these
headlines and you hear about this all
the time let's just get inside the mind
the weird bizarre Kinks and psyche of
the Trump supporter
we today pathologize ordinary behavior
and we normalize pathologies so we say
if you're a guy who doesn't want your
country to get invaded by a bunch of
foreigners or you're a guy who wants to
be able to walk down the street and not
be worried about getting mugged by the
spike in criminals uh you you've got
something wrong there's something in
your synapses in your amydala in the
frontal cortex that that is a marker of
your bizarre uh uh conservative
Affliction but if you're a dude who
thinks he's a chick you're totally
normal that's good actually you need a
firming procedures to to affirm your
normality because of how normal it
is the whole field of political
psychology is so
silly it's intrinsically
anti-conservative because it states that
the basis of politics is not
rational and I'm not saying that mankind
is perfectly rational uh far from it and
our politics today increasingly is quite
irrational on the left mostly not so
much on the right but we do have
faculties of reason we can perceive
objective reality we can talk about it
right if we can't we can't have
democracy so if the premise of these
headlines if the premise of political
psychology is true that it's all just
weird little ticks in our brain that we
were born with and that's the way we
understand each other is to put put
ourselves on the shrink couch and figure
out why we hate our parents or whatever
if that's the basis of politics then we
have to have some other form of
government which I guess is what they
want they hate the people they want to
dis disenfranchise as many people as
they can who are deplorable and
irredeemable and bitter clinging Bible
Thumpers and they believe that the
greatest threat to democracy is the
people picking the candidate they want
to vote for the most popular candidate
in the
race normal behavior that's a path
you're a you're a CIS man if you're
normal you're CIS but if you're if
you're a man who thinks he's a woman
you're just a woman how you shouldn't
even have to say you're just a that's
normal just up and down black is white
normality is pathology now speaking of
normalizing bad things a Navy veteran
this guy Michael cassid he's 35 years
old he's the guy who beheaded the
satanic statue that was exalted in the
Iowa state capital that
man has been charged with a hate
crime beheading a a satanic statue
erected in the capital is now a hate
crime are we the baddies I keep asking
this question it keeps coming up is is
Joe Biden more evil a ruler than xiin
ping or Vladimir Putin I know the latter
two guys they're bad they do all sorts
of bad stuff I know but like we we throw
military veterans into prison or we're
going to try to throw some military
veterans into prison
for objecting to a satanic Idol in a
government building and like a really
prominent government building are
we is Satanism now a protected religion
it's not a religion first of all not
even the satanists think that they are
in a religion the satanic temple says
that it is ironic they're just a bunch
of edgy Reddit atheists they don't they
believe that they're not actually
worshiping the devil the secret is they
are worshiping the devil because you
can't ironically worship the devil but
they think that they're atheists they
don't think they're a religion religion
is a
habit of virtue that inclines the will
to render to God the worship that he
deserves by no even remotely plausible
definition of religion do these
satanists
qualify Christians qualify I think Jews
can make a good case of qualifying I
think Muslims can make a good case of
qualifying even the non-theistic
religions Hinduism and
Buddhism can can make a less plausible
but still somewhat plausible case of
qualifying as a
religion these guys don't cuz they say
we're not religious
but second of all even if they really
were worshiping Satan that would be
worse and at no other point in American
history would we tolerate this the
founding fathers liberal-minded men are
rolling over in their graves thinking
about
this and then the third part it just
keeps getting more outrageous the third
part is there are regularly attacks on
churches in America that basically go
unpunished vandalism
attacks from Street criminals and from
the government the government shuts down
churches
too all during Co they tried to shut
down the churches and the synagogues for
that
matter that no no big deal there there
are no face act prosecutions by the
Biden Administration for that no no no
we've got to protect religious liberty
only in one case and the religious
liberty we're protecting is the
religious liberty of satanists are we
the baddies are we the baddies Nations
can go bad I hope we're not
bad I I would love my country no matter
what the political leaders are doing
because it's my country and it's an
extension of filial piety
but it's getting very difficult to
defend
this but xiin ping persecutes the
Muslims he does Vladimir Putin he you
know he's really bad I know he's really
bad he annexes territory that the Soviet
Union used to have I know it's bad it's
bad not defending
it we we take kids away from their
parents cuz the parents won't pretend
they're the opposite sex you know
sometimes leading to their suicide we uh
arrest prol liers for praying in
abortion centers we arrest them and
sentence them to over a decade in prison
and now we protect the rights of
satanists the so-called religious rights
of satanists more than than any other
religion any actual religion as far as I
can tell and we try to imprison Navy
Veterans for
that are we the baddies H it's a
question that we men have to ask
ourselves another question that we have
to ask ourselves a little more personal
pertains to hymns right now go to
hms.com did you know that 52% of men
over the age of 40 experience some form
of Ed with such a high percentage it is
strange that it's always been a taboo
topic hyms is changing men's healthc
Care by providing a simple process to
Affordable discreet Health treatments
all from the comfort of your couch all
you need to do is visit hms.com answer a
series of questions on their site and a
medical provider will determine the
right treat option if prescribed your
medication ships directly to you for
free and in discrete packaging HS
provides access to clinically proven
generic alternatives to Viagra and Calis
with options as low as two bucks per
dose no insurance needed you will pay
one low price for your treatments online
visits ongoing shipments and provider
messaging HS has hundreds of thousands
of trusted subscribers so if Ed is
getting you down it's time to change
that start your free online visit today
at hs.com
kwes that's HS
./n kwes for your personalized ed
treatment options visit hs.com
today turning to a much more gruesome
beheading
story little bit of a rough transition
but we're not just talking about statues
here we're talking about uh actual
people there is a story that went viral
yesterday about a young man I think a
32y old man who beheaded his father
allegedly picked up the head in a bag
made a YouTube video about it ranting
about all sorts of Politics the video
was up for hours on YouTube before it
got taken
down the father obviously is dead and
luckily the son has been captured the
story went viral one it's so gruesome so
sensationalist but two because the kid
kid he's 32-year-old man started uh
making all sorts of political claims and
so it's Being Framed by the media as
though he were a right Wing Trump
supporter because he attacked Joe Biden
and he attacked the government and all
the rest uh in the video the reason that
it's it's not going to take total hold
is in the video the guy apparently also
attacks Donald Trump and threatens
Donald Trump
so the media are going to spend a few
days trying to make this into a
political issue apparently the young man
was known to the FBI and you know
another one slips through the cracks I
guess uh they're going to try to make
this into a political issue it is a
reminder that there is more to life than
Republicans and Democrats there is more
to politics even than the left and the
right what was This Guy's political
ideology I don't know he certainly said
things that sound right-wing but then he
also threatened the Republican nominee
for president and he said he was the
leader of a cult and he was just
obviously a complete Looney Tune there
is a reality Beyond ideological
bickering and that reality is mental
illness legitimate mental illness not
not what the Liberals would say which is
that uh you know if you're if you want
to vote for a republican you know you
need to go to a psychiatrist but real
mental illness where you think you're
the second coming of the Messiah as this
guy did and where you're engaging in all
sorts of bizarre attention-seeking
behavior for a very long time and then
where you ultimately commit a heinous
evil crime and then make a big show
about it also why I'm not going to play
any of the video or say his name or any
you know that's obviously something he
was after in his much as he had rational
faculties and he doesn't seem to have
had much of those there's a reality of
mental illness and there's a reality of
evil and sometimes there's some overlap
there those are distinct
things mental illness is real and
demonic possession is real and they
don't always overlap sometimes it's one
sometimes it's the other sometimes the
distinction gets a little bit blurry
sometimes these things are brought on by
certain behaviors the kid talked a lot
about apparently how he smoked pot I
keep calling him a kid because it's he's
he's old though you know he's 32 years
old did his drug use have something to
do with it I who knows there is there is
a reality here and and ironically that's
what we won't talk about we never talk
about the existence of evil and really
modern fashionable people they can't
accept it because if you accept the
existence of evil you have to accept the
existence of good if you can exist if
you can accept the reality that some
things are better than other things then
there has to be a maximal good if
there's a moral order if there's a moral
law then there has to be a moral
lawgiver and you have to accept God and
that comes with certain uh requirements
the yoke is easy and the burden is light
but there is a yoke there there are some
requirements there we can know the
existence of God through our reason but
to know more about God and how to
worship him and you know religion this
thing that we treat in a very glib way
these days by protecting supposed rights
for satanists for edgy Reddit Edge Lord
satanists uh but
when we know things through our reason
then there are implications to that and
we follow that thread through Revelation
continuing to test our reason and we
talk about U our religious duties yeah
that's all out the window none of the
fashionable people do that ironically
though we don't even talk about mental
health we we have really glib shallow
articles about how you must have a screw
loose if you vote for a Republican and
then we pretend that obvious body
dysmorphia is totally normal especially
in the
and as well as deviant behaviors and
desires we say that's totally normal and
then we move along move along and then
we try to say that a a horrific heinous
crime that goes viral we say oh it's cuz
he's a right-winger you know and then
some people on the right will say no
he's a left-winger he like no he's he
watched too many Ben Shapiro videos or
no he watched whatever some guy on the
left I don't even know who are the guys
on the left there was that guy destiny
that Ben just Deb I don't know whoever
they say he watched too many his videos
there's more guys there's a little bit
more to life than that but the more we
ignore that the more we can expect to
see bizarre episodes and really evil
episodes such as this now speaking of
social media Mark Zuckerberg just had to
testify before the Senate and he was
grilled by Senator Josh Holly on the uh
awful effects especially for young
people and he was asked to make an
apology so you didn't take any action
you didn't take you didn't anybody you
haven't compensated a single victim let
me ask you this let me ask you this
there's families of victims here today
have you apologized to the victims I
would you like to do so now well they're
here you're on National Television would
you like now to apologize to the victims
who have been harmed by your product
show them the
pictures would you like to apologize for
what you've done to these good
people I'm
sor to go through the things that your
families have have suffered and this is
why we invested so much and are going to
continue doing industry efforts to uh to
make sure that no one has to go through
the types of things that your families
have had to
suffer you know why Mr Zuckerberg why
should your company not be sued for this
why is it that you can claim you hide
behind a liability Shield you can't be
held accountable shouldn't you be held
accountable
personally I thought Zuckerberg handled
this beautifully actually all he asking
a legitimate question which is hey you
your technology has led to all sorts of
terrible consequences from young people
and you haven't done enough to fix it so
should you apologize to these the
parents of these young people who have
been so hurt or in some cases perhaps
killed themselves and instantly
Zuckerberg gets up they start to stand
up he stands up and he apologizes this
looked really good it is the right thing
to do and moreover I don't think
Zuckerberg Bears most of the
blame it social media is generally
terrible for young people in some cases
it can be good if it's really really
tightly controlled if you're like
listening to the Michael show right now
and you're a member of the in the Inner
Circle and you're in the chat with very
wholesome smart people okay that can be
good but if you're a young person and
you're on Tik Tok or you're on Tumblr
you're on any of these other plat I
don't know if do people do Tumblr
anything more I don't know I interviewed
a a an
ex who said that Tumblr radicalized her
but I don't know maybe they're probably
on some other one now all of those
Instagram Facebook obviously both owned
by Mark Zuckerberg all of them can lead
you down a very bad path how are they
getting on those
Technologies that's my question I don't
want to point fingers at the parents
necessarily but parents are a big part
of it are the parents buying their kids
smartphones bad idea really bad idea
they shouldn't be doing that it's crazy
crazy to do that
today these smartphones are portals to
hell and if you are adult and educated
and well-formed maybe you can avoid the
worst of it maybe if you're very
disciplined about your social media use
and you're not too curious and you know
you develop good habits maybe you can
avoid the Temptations in that portal to
Hell All Sorts by the way I'm not even
just talking about like weird sex stuff
which is probably what most people think
of when they they think about the
Temptations of the internet but all of
it all sorts of crazy stuff sloth you're
just Doom scrolling forever you know you
get addicted just to the those dopamine
hits or our wrath you know you're just
sending out vicious awful things on
Twitter and there's so it's just pride
of course you're just obsessed with your
image and posting pictures of your
spaghetti or whatever every deadly sin
is
is a major Temptation on social media
why would a parent do
that I'll tell you why because the
parents need to reach the kids okay get
the kid a flip phone well no no you
don't understand Michael the kids
friends the kids friends all have the
smartphones okay well why do your kids
friends have smartphones why are they
friends with those people well because
the their kids are in public school okay
I get it man it's really hard private
school is very very expensive and priv
and in most cases really not not any
better than the public schools in that
regard and maybe you want a homeschool
but you need the money so you got to go
out to work there's no one to homeschool
or there's not a good homeschooling
Co-op near you or there's this or
there's that or I know the system is set
up against you I'm I'm not denying any
of that but we can't just go along to
get along anymore with these sorts of
issues it this is not like techn
technological advancements when you were
a kid same thing that's being taught in
schools we say all the schools have
always been leftwing yeah they weren't
chopping kids genitals off 20 years ago
actually that's a that's a Mar change
and so 20 years ago you send your kid to
public school all right they're probably
going to turn a little Lefty but what
are we going to do yeah now they're
going to chop your kids genitals off so
that's a that's now you can't now the
calculation changes and it is incumbent
upon you to figure something out and
it's incumbent Upon Us in the political
order to figure something out but it is
not all Mark Zuckerberg's fault I'm no
big promoter of Facebook and obviously
of social media at all are these Tech
zillionaires but and this guy you know
Zuckerberg may have been one of the most
significant factors in kicking Donald
Trump out of the white house so I I
there's no love lost here for Mark
Zuckerberg but it is not all that guy's
fault now speaking of scandalizing kids
there is a Doctor Who's gone viral on
social media for saying that she will
die on the hill of i' been alone so long
but this
time
with she makes a few declarative
statements we have to it will really
help them if you don't do that they'll
kill themselves if you and I will die on
this hill but then she gets to the last
one and the last one's the really
important one you have to live your
truth and this is this is this is the
receipt that I'm going to save it when I
bring liberalism to court when I when I
we put liberalism on trial and we try to
scrap the whole damn thing not just
modern progressivism but even some of
the early Classical liberalism the
supposedly good liberalism I'm bringing
that receipt to court because that is
the sort of thing that John Stewart Mill
was talking about that's the sort of
thing that you see in the earlier
Enlightenment writers but just live your
truth let's just not violate the harm
principle the notion that the the
government should should only interfere
when you might harm others through your
behavior but if it's just about you it's
just your own personal life
the government has no right whatsoever
to interfere you get to do whatever you
want to yourself because as actually
John Stewart Mill understood though he
didn't sufficiently
answer what happens in private spills
out into public and a society that that
establishes as its basis something this
low this basic this this brittle and
weak is not a society that's going to
flourish for very long now speaking of
things coming to an end your life will
come to an end that is why you got to
check out trust and will right now go to
trust and will.com slns from maintaining
control of your assets to easing the
burden on your loved ones an estate plan
can ensure that your family is prepared
and protected if you are looking for a
way to set up your estate to offer
Financial benefits and more you need to
check out trust and will traditional
estate planning can cost thousands of
dollars many one-size fit-all solutions
may not capture all the important
details of the life you've built with
trust and will you can protect your
legacy from the comfort of your home
starting at just 159 bucks they have
simplified the process of creating and
managing your will or Trust online from
finding out what's right for your family
to finalizing documents with a notary I
have had a will I've had a number of
Wills since I was 18 years old it's very
very important to be responsible protect
your family especially if you've got
kids make sure you know what's going to
happen with your kids I love trust and
will makes the process so so simple and
so affordable right now secure your
assets and protect your loved ones with
trust and will get 10% off plus free
shipping of your estate plan documents
by visiting trustand will.com that's 10%
off and free shipping at trustand
will.com
klees you've got to live your truth says
the woman who wants to and she will die
on this
hill but
her her truth is that boys can become
girls and she's going to live without
her Truth
by my truth is that boys can't become
girls so one of our truths has to be
false but okay let's just we're look in
my in my family we don't we don't chop
people's genitals off and in maybe in
her family or what in whatever kind of
community she's got they do and look
that's her business and that's my how
does it affect me you know how does it
affect
you here's how it affects me uh because
the woman is making a declarative
statement about human nature in reality
and uh when that view is accepted by
anyone it is going to spill out into
society and how we treat the very
Notions of men and women and that's
going to spill out into the schools
around me and the communities around me
and my
family that because we live in a
society that's how so we're going to
need some basis of society that is more
uh forceful that is more um thorough and
comprehensive than don't yuck my yum bro
because these people are willing to die
on the hill of and they've got access to
your kid now because your kid has a
smartphone and is on Tik Tok and sees
that crazy lady and if you want to
protect your kid from that you can take
away the phone you can take the kid out
of school you going lock the kid in his
bedroom studying the classics but
Society is going to make its way inent
which is why we have an obligation to
defend reality because it's good for
everybody and it's it's going to affect
us eventually as well speaking of
political polarization even with the
extreme degree of political polarization
we have these days we can't even agree
on basic terms or aspects of human
nature there's some bipartisan support
going on Anthony scaramucci the mooch
the shortest serving White House
communications director in history
lasted 11 days worked for Donald Trump
well now he is
endorsing Joe
Biden and here is his convoluted
reasoning why I've been a lifelong
Republican I've sort of been in the you
the Mitt Romney jet Bush community of
the Republican party uh and I have a lot
of respect for governor Haley but I
think you have to be honest about where
the situation is uh the former president
will win this nomination unless there's
some type of legal Avalanche that takes
place from the Department of Justice or
perhaps one of the states but even in
that situation those proceedings take
longer than usual uh and I think we do
have a rematch and I'm a patriot first
and a partisan second and so I'm going
to go with the institutions of the
democracy and the checks and balances of
the system and not somebody that's
talking about tyranny and talking about
being a dictator for a day or using the
Department of Justice to persecute his
political
adversaries hold on hold on wait a
second Anthony
scaramucci is not going to vote for
Donald Trump because Donald
Trump might have
insinuated that for a day he would be
tempted to use the Department of Justice
to persecute his political
opponents
hypothetically so instead he's going to
vote for Joe Biden who is actually doing
that right this second he is Prosecuting
Donald Trump because Donald Trump is the
leader of the Republican
party this after Donald Trump was was
already persecuted by the doj and the
FBI from the very moment he started
running for president you had the doj
spying on him and then working with the
Democrats to cook up fake information
working with Hillary looking working
with the Obama White House to cook up a
fake dossier that that would be a
pretext for trying to undermine the
whole Trump Administration if he somehow
got elected which he did so so you're
going to vote for the guy who did
everything that you're afraid Donald
Trump jokingly suggested he might be
kind of inclined to do for a day that's
not really good reasoning I think the I
think Anthony scaramucci's reasoning has
more to do with the first part the first
part of his statement was look I'm a
lifelong Republican I'm a Mitt Romney
Jeb Bush kind of
Republican he's a liberal Mitt Romney in
vented Obamacare Mitt Romney when he was
running for Senate Massachusetts
disavowed Ronald Reagan and George Bush
actually said I I wasn't a republican in
the time of Reagan Bush I I was an
independent during the time of Reagan
Bush I don't want to go back to Reagan
Bush he's a scaramucci is a a liberal a
liberal Republican he's a liberal who
wants lower taxes okay I'm not even
knocking it I I have many friends who
have this view I have family members who
are of this
view but don't pretend to me it's
because Donald Trump is some grave
threat to democracy because Donald Trump
is maybe thinking about doing the things
that Joe Biden is currently doing he
already won your vote
apparently and and please also don't
pretend to me that you are a lifelong
Republican as though that really means
anything in this ideological fight the
Liberal Republicans have been teaming up
with the Democrats to pull this move for
now over what it's about six years now
this happened during the Goldwater
campaign the Democrats found some squish
Rhino to to go on and and say look I'm a
republican but I'm not one of those
Republicans I certainly don't feel
guilty about being a republican I've
always been a
republican my father is his father was
the whole family is a republican family
I voted for Dwight Eisenhower the first
time I ever voted I voted for Nixon the
last
time but when we come to Senator
Goldwater now it seems to me we're up
against a very different kind of a
man this man scares
me now maybe I'm wrong A friend of mine
has said to me listen just because a a
man sounds a little irresponsible during
a campaign doesn't mean he's going to
act irresponsibly you know that theory
that the White House makes the
man I don't buy
that sometimes I I wish I'd been at that
convention in San
Francisco I bet that guy does wish he
was in San Francisco we'll leave that to
the imagination that ad could have been
produced by the Lincoln project against
Donald Trump that ad could have been
produced by the Rhino establishment
against Ronald Reagan they said all the
same things time and time again and what
I resent about it is the notion that
listen I'm a lifelong Republican means
anything because the ideological battle
that we're talking about is not the
Republicans versus the democr the
ideological battle we're talking about
is the conservatives versus the low tax
liberals that's what it's really about
and what scaramucci with the mooch
is somewhat honestly explaining here or
or demonstrating is that those low tax
rhinos don't have very much in common
with the conservatives the conservatives
have gone along with the low tax rhinos
the low tax liberals for a long
time when they nominate Romney we just
kind of suck it up and vote for him
maybe he's not our favorite he invented
Obamacare he's a huge lib but whatever
he's the Republican number we'll vote
for him John
McCain pretty big lib on a lot of issues
I respect his military service of course
but you know he's kind of a Democrat
half a Dem at least we voted for
him the bushes we we do it okay we go
along with it but when it comes to the
low tax liberals voting for The
conservatives then they're out then they
say no thank you sorry we're we're with
the Lincoln project now we're endorsing
Biden we're endorsing
Hillary because they have much more in
common with the
Liberals when it comes to the so-called
social policies by the way we're talking
about Society here so the social
policies seem pretty important they side
with the Liberals when when it comes to
epistemology you know how how we can
know anything when it comes to
anthropology what we know about man they
go with the Liberals and when it comes
to the basis of political philosophy
they go along with the Liberals you you
do you in this case though don't make me
pay more taxes that's not what the
conservatives think the conservatives
think there's a Transcendent moral order
the conservatives think that norms and
standards are good the conservatives
think that patriotism is a good thing
conservatives believe that borders are a
good conservatives realize that
limits are what give shape to beautiful
things if you don't have limits then the
beautiful sonnet turns into slam poetry
and slam poetry is the death of Art if
you don't have limits then the nation
becomes just a blob to be invaded by
foreigners as it currently is
being I'm a lifelong Republican but I'm
not voting for this Trump man man you
worked for Trump are you kidding me we
stop telling go oh he might be Hitler
he's not Hitler he's just somewhat more
conservative than the libs you guys want
to run and that's too much for you too
bad too bad maybe these lifelong
Republicans should admit they've been
lifelong Democrats the whole time as for
Trump's numbers they're looking pretty
good Bloomberg News and morning consult
has Trump leading Biden in all seven
swing States so you're going to see a
lot of headlines National polls right
after Trump for all intents and purposes
clinched the nomination you saw all
these polls shift nationally Trump is
losing to Biden okay well the election
is not National the Democrats could
still steal it a million different ways
but if you look at the polls in the
swing States right now Trump 47 Biden 44
it's close but Trump is up by three
Georgia Trump 49 Biden 41 that's a
pretty big gap Michigan Trump 47 Biden
42 still pretty big gap Five Points
Nevada Trump 48 Biden 40 eight points
pretty good North Carolina Trump's up 10
points 49 to 39 Pennsylvania even there
these worries that Trump might not win
Pennsylvania he's up three points at
least according to Bloomberg News and
morning consult it's a Liberal Liberal
poll Wisconsin 49 to 44 Five Points
still pretty good now what happens when
you factor in RFK Jr because there's
been a fear RFK junors he's going to
take votes from Trump he could he could
actually tilt the election to Biden
that's not my view I think that he'll
take votes from both candidates probably
won't take a lot of votes but in as much
as he takes votes from candidates it'll
mostly be from Biden well you you show
Kennedy in the race Trump still
[Applause]
wins Arizona 43-35 Biden Georgia 44-
37 Michigan 43 to 37 Nevada it looks
even better Trump's up 12 points when
you put RFK in the race it's looking
pretty
good I feel good about our chances Nikki
Haley will continue to run but the
writing is clearly on the wall she's not
even running in Nevada and South
Carolina she's going to get trounced in
her home State Michigan she's going to
get trounced that's all before super
Tuesday uh so it would seem there are
reports now that some of Haley's big
funders are closing their checkbooks
because they don't think they're going
to get a return on the investment so I'm
not I'm not with the the RNC here in for
Nikki Haley to drop out of the race but
for all intents and purposes Trump is
the nominee and the the early numbers
look pretty good you might say who
trusts the polls Michael are you a big
dummy to trust the polls well no
sometimes I trust the polls sometimes I
don't and I look for evidence on which
to base my decision and the polls in
this race thus far in Iowa and in New
Hampshire have been reliable they've
been really really close to what's
happened and so maybe the polls will be
reliable moving forward the Biden
Administration needs to do something and
and
uh the economy maybe they'll be able to
putter through with some facade of a
strong economy through the election
maybe but the potential World War that's
breaking out in the Middle East is a big
problem so that war has been brought on
basically through Biden's incompetence
and bad political Vision don't forget
Donald Trump brought peace to the Middle
East in the Abraham Accords got Saudi
Arabia to sit down with the Israelis
Biden blew it all up and now there's
there's a war uh Joe Biden it actually
Bears the blame even more directly for
the Ukraine war president zalinski in
Ukraine said if not for Joe Biden's weak
stance on Russia they would not have
invaded Ukraine so he bears that
responsibility so what is Biden going to
do you know to quote Barack Obama you
should never underestimate Joe's ability
to F things up Joe Biden is now
according to reports from axios
exploring options to recognize a
Palestinian state
that'll solve the problem more on that
in a second first though you know lady
Ballers is the hilarious story of how a
group of male losers who can't win
against other men decide to identify as
women and join a women's basketball
league yes it's absurd it's ridiculous
it's laughable
yes it's happening right now in the
world here's a quick look at what is
being called the most triggering movie
of the
decade leftists are losing it over lady
Ballers nothing's changed this movie is
a straightup and intentional transphobic
hate crime what I see you the lady
Ballers movie needs to be banned I'll
cancel you I get the blinds please to
11 the most toxic BS you've ever seen
you're a Monster yeah next level hate
speech propaganda that's it that's the
pitch watch the most triggering comedy
of the
decade lady Ballers streaming
exclusively on Deli w
plus I don't know about you but I'm
triggered don't wait watch lady Ballers
the movie that Hollywood did not make so
we did exclusively on dailywire plus
right
now my favorite comment yesterday is
from moon mission passage to Tali 1952
that's a very long name who says if
Taylor Swift endorses a 2024
presidential candidate it will likely be
RFK Jr Taylor Swift dated his son Connor
Kennedy Old Joe's too much of a
liability hold I I actually had
forgotten I remember that that um Taylor
Swift had dated one of the Kennedy kids
I'd forgotten that it was RFK Jr's kid
but I'm not sure I follow your logic
here if
your exboyfriend or girlfriend's dad
were running for president would you be
more or less inclined to vote for that
person maybe maybe you'd be inclined to
do it I'm just thinking usually when
someone becomes an ex it's because
you're not that favorably inclined to
that person anymore so I don't
maybe RFK Jr would be the last person
Taylor Swift would endorse just as a
political matter there's seems to me
zero chance she would endorse him one it
might make K Travis Kelce jealous two
RFK Jr is being portrayed as the biggest
cook in the race I don't think he is
exactly but he's being portrayed as even
cookier than Donald Trump by the media
so I just I don't know why if she were
going to do that she might as well just
go and endorse Trump which probably she
can't do but you know I'm still I'm
still Pro Swifty
I'm real Swifty these days all right not
because I would ever voluntarily listen
to any of her music
but she's a nice pretty girl who dresses
normal and conducts herself with class
and is dating a football player and it's
that's that is dispositionally
temperamentally
conservative I I discovered this about
my wife years and years ago before my
you know now of course my wife is
slightly to the right of Francisco
Franco she all makes us look like you
know uh Hillary Clinton but before that
time when she wasn't thinking that much
about politics she's focused on other
things she you know I I spend all my day
thinking about politics and she hadn't
really thought about them too much but
even at that point she
was dispositionally probably more
conservative than I am she just conducts
herself with in in a more normal
way frankly with probably greater
dignity and class most of the time and
that and Taylor's she got that okay she
baked the Joe Biden cookies okay
whatever we're not going to win we're
not going to win a war turning on Taylor
Swift who is one of the most
conservative elements of American pop
culture damning perhaps that is to us
but that's how it is some people don't
think it be like it is but it do to
quote Oscar gamble now Joe Biden has a
solution to the potential outbreak of
World War III focused in particular
around the Middle East and the solution
is give the Palestinian Arabs a
state that'll that'll do it right what
could go wrong uh I don't know how real
this possibility is it's clearly being
floated though because it's an axios
Secretary of State Tony blinkin asked
the state department to conduct a review
and present policy options on possible
us and international recognition of a
Palestinian state after the war in Gaza
okay well there's your first problem
there's never going to be an end to the
war in Gaza they're just going to drag
The War Out forever because the Israeli
National interest is to get the
Palestinians out of Gaza because the
Palestinians they have concluded
represent an unacceptable security risk
and fair enough if I were an Israeli
Minister I'd probably come to the same
conclusion not saying that clearing the
Palestinians out of Gaza is in America's
interest exactly but if I were Israeli
that's certainly what I would think so
they're just going to keep dragging this
out this war has been going on for what
110 days now and they're just going to
keep dragging it on and then because of
the Lindy effect it's the longer it goes
on the more likely it will continue to
go on even longer so okay forget about
that this is according to two US
officials briefed on the issue I have no
doubt that that Biden and the Democrats
want to recognize some kind of
Palestinian
State and I sympathize with the
Palestinians I TR I truly do and I'm not
making any theological or grand
political claim that the Israeli
government has the permanent right
forever and ever you know more
fundamental than any other political
right to that that strip of
land I've got I guess I've got a more
practical question than all of that
which
is what does the US get out of
recognizing a Palestinian State put a
put aside the fact that any Palestinian
state is basically
impractical I don't re you've got the
you've got Gaza then you've got Israel
and then you've got the West Bank and
you're going to make a Palestinian State
out of two territories that are
extremely densely populated that are
separated by their sworn
enemy and then in the Charter the Hamas
Charter Hamas which governs Gaza you've
got the the basic aim of the state is to
destroy the state in between you and the
other part of your state in W
practically I have no idea how that's
going to work but again I'm not making
any claims about the land and who's got
the right to it and bringing in some
Grand theological claim novel or
otherwise what do we get out of that why
on Earth would we do that well
because that will pacify the
Palestinians or the Iranians who are
backing a lot of this conflict oh it
will really yeah you just give them a
little bit more land and and
then how how is that supposed to pacify
them the aim of Iran and of the
Palestinian Arabs is to obliterate
Israel as long as the United States
funds Israel we fund 6 and a half% of
the Israeli military we we treat Israel
as one of our greatest allies on the
face of the Earth as long as we continue
to do that and prop up the state of
Israel they're going to hate us still
it's not you think it's going to be good
enough are you kidding me are you that
naive so okay
maybe you're of the persuasion that we
should just ditch Israel and you know
get out of that Alliance and stop giving
them money and stop Rob okay and and
then when we do that the Israelis major
war will break out and potentially the
Jews get wiped out in the region
and one is that is that a good thing but
two put those moral considerations aside
for a second how does that benefit us
how does any of this benefit us like
what ah oh man I don't I'm not saying
I'm count Von metni here I'm not saying
that I am the the greatest Grand
strategic thinker in the world
but I do know that the Biden
Administration and these doofuses who
are running the state department I do
know that they are pretty much the worst
Grand strategic thinkers in the world so
so anyone else is probably doing better
than them when it comes to international
relations just looking at the track
record of Joe Biden here two major Wars
breaking out just in the three years
that he's been around um I think it's
safe to say that whatever they are
inclined to do do the
opposite speaking of
jihadis jihadis are threatening more
attacks on
Americans uh according to Sami Abu zurri
a senior Hamas spokesperson
oh I hate you see how the Liberals
infect your language they make you speak
their PC gobble spokes
person like spokes per daughter you
can't say son that's masculine this this
Hamas spokesman says the killing of
three
Americans uh is a message to the
American Administration that unless the
killing of innocent people in Gaza stops
it must uh confront the entire um so the
entire Arab Muslim world
uh the continuation of the American
Zionist aggression against Gaza is
capable of setting the entire region
Ablaze
okay the the Israeli the the rational
Israeli aim in the war is to get rid of
the Palestinians in Gaza not saying
necessarily kill all of them but you
know just get them out of the region
because they say it's a big too big a
security threat the aim of the
Palestinians and the government
representatives of the Palestinians is
to get rid of the Israelis
I'm not saying necessarily by killing
all of them though probably they
wouldn't be opposed to it uh but even
just getting them to move back somewhere
else all right that's it the the aim of
these two groups that are at war is the
total annihilation of the other
group so are we going to are We As
Americans going to support either of
those things no I don't think
so seems pretty ghastly I don't I don't
see an American Administration even in a
republican one saying we're just going
to get rid of all we're going to
ethnically cleanse the Palestinian
territories and likewise I don't see an
Administration even the most left-wing
one saying we're going to just route all
the Jews out of Israel so neither of the
the war aims for these two
belligerant are in our interest so the
only thing that can be in our interest
is to get the war to wind down to
contain it and to get the war to wind
down and not drag on forever that's it
because the longer it drags on the
bigger the opportunity for it to
escalate as it already has the more that
our troops are In Harm's Way the more
likely they will be attacked because
they know that we're bankrolling the
state of Israel and and so the the only
thing that we can do if we really want
to ramp this down is if if we want to
really really minimize our risk is to
contain and ramp down the war between
these two belligerant that's the Reagan
Doctrine that's what Reagan did in
Lebanon and that's what we we always
invoke St Ronald St Ronald of the
Blessed Rawhide well uh we we might
might take his views into consideration
today okay speaking of bad news Elmo has
gone viral Elmo like the the Muppet he's
gone viral for
asking how everyone's doing that's it
said H Elmo here I guess that's Mickey
that's I can't I can't do a good
professor Jacob do you can you do an
Elmo hi hi that's pretty good actually
he has a good one I don't I I huh homo
checking in how's everybody
doing forgive the impression that's
simple enough right and there was a
deluge of whining that came out it was
funny a lot of it was ironic some of it
maybe wasn't uh David lit said Elmo I'm
suffering from existential
dread from
hopelessness someone said every morning
I cannot wait to go back to sleep every
Monday I cannot wait for Friday to come
every single day and every single week
of the year uh Zigler Rachel Zigler who
is that she's playing the new Snow White
in the Disney movie she goes resisting
the urge to tell Elmo I'm kind of sad
and so some of these are funny some a
lot of these are funny and good good
responses but I just responded I said
I'm doing doing very well thank you for
asking
because whatever happened to suffering
in silence huh whatever happened to kiss
it up to God and keep your mouth shut
and have a step upper lip why I know
that a lot of these are jokes but I have
noticed people whine and complain about
their own supposed suffering all the
time and we know we live in a victim
economy now where being able to claim
some struggle will will get you more
social currency and so everyone does it
all the time and it's really annoying I
have to catch myself oh I'm tired I oh I
don't have any more cigars oh I oh no
the cigar bar closed before I finish
wrapping my show in Santa Barbara so I'm
not going to be whatever it is okay I'm
just using hypotheticals
here you got to cut it out complain it's
like it's like radon in a home you know
it just kind of per it's poison that you
don't really notice right away and it
just ah it just makes you sick and cut
it out when Elmo asks you how you doing
you say you say I'm doing well thank you
Elmo how are you all right that's our
show it is theology Thurs and though I
am on the road and though I'm not able
to necessarily interact because
Professor Jacob didn't bring me my
special iPad so I'm going to have to
defenestrate him we did get an interview
with my friend Father Benedict Keeley
all the way from across the ocean from
Canterbury so we'll bring that on for
theology Thursday we'll get to the
mailbag tomorrow and then I'll get to
interact with you in real time again
very very
soon
[Music]
a